[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
avec une actualité très chargée pour
parler de justice et politique on va
parler de l'immigration va parler de
start-up aussi avec florence mercadé ou
bonjour je batterie iv au barreau de
versailles jean charles lajoie dit
bonjour aux éditeurs toujours on parlera
tout à l'heure de votre dernière
parution jackpot
le chef-d'oeuvre absolu et parce que
c'est politiquement incorrect tout ce
qui va vous plaire très bien et qui va
perdre stéphane haumant sont surtout ces
injections
bonjour patrice et professeur à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
ça va bien très bien merci et mac dan
lambeaux conduit
bonjour alors vous êtes la fondatrice de
gulbis tout à fait et vous allez nous
dire ce que younis d'accord c'est très
simple c'est une astuce stop c'est une
start-up intervention 360 je dirais à
communication marketing pour les start
up et les pme d'accord vous occupez donc
des autres tomes
j'interviens sur différents domaines et
vous êtes-vous à guyancourt dans le dans
le ce qu'on appelle causa de le
réceptacle des start-up saison donc on
va voir avec vous parce que il ya eu le
président de la république justement
notre genre reçu il ya une réception à
l'elysée où il mauvais justement aux
entreprises d'investir un peu plus dans
les start up et c'est vrai qu'on est
assez en retard au fond d'eau les noms
les nouvelles technologies en france et
en europe
on en parlera tout à l'heure mais
l'événement on va commencer par
l'événement
[Musique]
alors l'événement c'est de les rapports
entre la justice et la politique
il ya beaucoup d'affaires il ya eu le
procès balkany ya actuellement la sphère
mélenchon il y aussi ce jugement plus
peut-être commencer par la zone à savoir
ce que vous en pensiez du tribunal de
lyon qui a relaxé des écologistes qui
avaient décroché des portraits du
président de la république et ils ont
pour pour relaxer c'est ce écologistes
on a invoqué le principe de de l'état de
nécessité qui veut réagir vite sur cette
décision déjà oui alors en fait l'état
de nécessité c'est une création
jurisprudentielle qui datent de mémoire
1885 enfin enfin puisque ces cités par
exemple quelqu'un vole et ce n'est pas
la vie nécessite oui mais c'est une
création jurisprudentielle donc c'est
pas dans que donne avec une définition
dans le code pénal et donc l'état de
nécessité peut recouvrer tout type
d'état de nécessité et pas exclusivement
le fait d'une femme qui va les volets du
pain parce que il faut qu'il donne à
manger à ses enfants
l'état de nécessité tels que ça a été
développé le juge a lyon c'est de dire
qu' il y avait il ya un espèce de vide
politique actuelle du gouvernement sur
les problématiques écologiques et qui à
l'état de nécessité de réagir par
rapport à cette problématique
environnementale qui est une
problématique dramatique et est évidente
et que le fait alors c'est pas qu'ils
les décrocher ils ont été poursuivis
pour vol parce qu'en fait ils l'ont
décroché ils l'ont pris et donc quand on
se retrouve sur le vol comme le vol
dans les supermarchés ou de pain selon
justement sur cette nécessité seconde il
ya le décrochage est envolé il y avait
une nécessité pour oui c'est ça le fait
qu'ils aient décroché et qu'ils soient
partis avec
c'est un état de nécessité pour alerter
le notamment l'autorité de l'état sur le
fait qu'il ya un vide qui ne font pas
assez pour l'environnement est ce que
c'est juste de dire ou faire assez ou
pas assez pour l'environnement c'est
seul problème
oui mais est-ce que c'est un état de
nécessité que d'alerter le politique
si les mêmes décrocheurs décide
d'enlever un adjoint au maire sur la mer
selon le même procédé l'état de
nécessité liée à surtout surtout au vol
après j'ai trouvé que la place était de
la planète là n'ont pas placé la planète
mais c'est lié au vol oui donc donc
quand la planète le vol en a même et le
rapt ont damé passe donc c'est des juges
qui vont décider que pour les messieurs
c'est que le modèle des juges de jean
jouzel et années de dire si la politique
est bonne pas bonne ce gros c'est ça
c'est le début de la fin non mais ces
juges là et en dehors de cette de cette
affaire est un juge qui est sur les
affaires les plus spéciales à lyon il
n'est pas réputé pour être quelqu'un de
gauche révolutionnaire
pas du tout c'est quelqu'un de qui
applique qui appliquent le code et qui
est pas forcément laxistes donc s'il l'a
fait c'est avec un raisonnement
juridique
voilà moi j'ai lu j'ai lu le
jugement et très franchement je trouve
que c'est pas du tout choquant sur cette
question très honnêtement je ne serai
pas je serai pas forcément très
compétente pour quoi alors alors stephen
ferris
mais enfin je suis pas là bas nous avons
une juriste qui dit abbas et le jugement
et pas au fond on peut l'appeler on
verra ce que la pour rappel d'hier
faisait déjà appel mais moi qui ne suis
pas joueur je suis prêt à parier sur le
web
évidemment la censure de la censure de
ce jeu bien entendu parce que l'avion
oui parce que je sur le plan strictement
juridique que l'état de nécessité c'est
ce que c'est ce que m mercadet choqué ok
mais en oubliant quand même un détail
c'est que l'état de nécessité est
jusqu'à présent du moins à moins d'un
revirement mais c'est pas un juge unique
qui va qui va en être à l'origine
l'état de nécessité c'est que c'est
conçu comme étant le l'ultime moyen pour
justifier la commission d'un fait
qualifiable d'infraction de là à se dire
que le moyen ultime pour alerter
non seulement le pouvoir politique mais
l'opinion publique sur les questions
liées au dérèglement climatique
ces deux volets des portraits du
président la république dans les mairies
c'est là que ça ne tient pas dans le
caractère ultime du moyen il n'y a pas
d'autres se finir quand on est là des
stats et ses cités on peut pas faire
autrement voilà grosso et voilà ce que
veut dire d'enlever cet été était
nécessité n'y a pas d'autre solution et
c'est en cela que sur le plan juridique
ce jugement de mon point de vue ne tient
pas alors il ya le point de vue
juridique mais il ya quand même un point
de vue politique quand même c'est une
intense et une intervention dans la
politique d'un juge du droit non est-ce
que c'est au juge de dire on en fait
assez ou pas assez en matière d'écologie
mais ça pose cette question quand même
et puis ça pose aussi une autre question
se faire que c'est légitime et la
désobéissance civile c'est légitime et
le non respect de la loi enfin ça ça
envoie un message
à la population qu absolument monstrueux
en disant bah oui si la cause est bonne
à les y lâchez vous faites ce que vous
voulez quoi la jeunesse qu'est m
par définition souvent un peu
irresponsable enfin là ça va être
démentiel voix des bombes à ok on y va
on a le talent blanc seing de la justice
on est on est soutenus on peut me faire
ce qu'on veut faire c'est pour une bonne
cause allons-y la loi c'est pas grave
c'est pour les autres c c et demandons
aux gens qui polluent de respecter la
loi mais nous on est contre la pollution
donc on peut s'affranchir de la loi
moi ce que je veux dire c'est un message
qui est ici des jeunes qu'on essaie de
former s'y retrouve avec un des messages
pareil là je chapeau alors j'attendais
d'autres jours philippe tesson qui
disait avec un peu de malice à vassy le
jugement de deux millions 10,1 les
balkany peuvent faire ce qu'ils veulent
mais qu'est ce qui veut dire c'est de
dire que si vous voilà ainsi tout est
possible 13 à l'eau dit justement sur la
ferme balkany alors hier le jugement
était ce qui d après ce qui est ce qui
peut faire débat en tout cas c'est le
fait que on les a mis en prison
immédiatement comme s'ils étaient
dangereux pour la société qu'il a les
vieux les enfants enfin je ne sais pas
c'est pas pour ça parce que le fait de
demander à de fait de déposer un mandat
de dépôt et que le mandat de dépôt soit
accordée par par le tribunal
c'est pour non pas l'histoire de
troubles à l'ordre public mais c'est
pour éviter que la personne s'enfuit et
on peut se poser la question quand on
sait que s'il avait dû s'enfuir il
faudrait profite depuis longtemps non
parce que je pense que son passeport de
plus depuis deux ans oui mais
l'homme peut s'annoncer n'empêche que
sans passeport oui mais là je porte dans
ce que le ce que le tribunal a retenu
c'est que une personne qui est une
personne publique qui détient l'autorité
publique notamment en étant mère puisse
commettre des fraudes
à ce niveau là et quand même il est
condamné pour ça et je pense que
derrière leur tête
au mois d'octobre il va y avoir un
jugement qui va être je pense assez
sévère qu'il va tomber et ils appliquent
craignait qu à mon avis c'est pas ce qui
est dit dans la décision sur le mandat
de dépôt je pense qu'il craignait que
qu'ils puissent qu'ils puissent s'enfuir
et que juste pour ça alors quand même si
on reprend gillot mais si on reprend non
c'est un véhicule et s'enfuir devant un
avocat se réjouir de la belle image
explique mais on sent que les sourires
oui je sais ce qu'il attendait ce qu'il
a fait extrêmement grave c'est quelqu'un
parce que l'afld est extrêmement grave
de double non mais juste on se dit le
jugement reconnaît qu'il ya pas un
détournement de fonds de 2 de france vif
non mais c'est parce que j'en trouve 10
dans les fraudes fiscales 11 millions
comment à conscription c'est par ce fait
contestable oui mais là ça porte sur 4
millions voilà non mais comment
quelqu'un qui représente l'état 2 ne
peut ne pas voir les minimes alors
pourquoi jérôme cahuzac qui était
ministre du budget qui était chargé de
poursuivre la fraude fiscale n'a pas été
l'un de ceux d'un jour en prison qui
elle menti devant la représentation
nationale devant le président de la
république vous déplacez pas politique
pour balkany c'est quand même deux poids
deux mesures l'homme ajouté quand même
ministre du ministre du budget chargé de
poursuivre le front fiscal qui fraudent
lui même et on le volume est un petit
bracelet
au niveau de monsieur balkany ya puis
après je veux dire la cour d'appel la
cour la structure d'affaires ministre du
budget il a la pression de la
collection des livres vinyles ce type
fini c'est un virage les murs c'est
peut-être je terminais non mais
j'attendais pardon je ne demande pas
qu'on le mette en prison
je m'étonne quand même que je l'aï
jamais parlé de représentants de l'état
y avait un kit est plus représentant de
l'état claude n'est pas le remède n'est
pas sur le même niveau de fraude
bon donc et à monsieur balkany lui l'a
jamais regretté il a il est fier de lui
quoi casser le jeu larter et comment ce
type il dangereux pour la société
puisqu'il ne paye pas ses impôts
le fait de pas payé ses impôts ses
danseuses oui ça fait des trous dans le
budget de l'état
je sache que c'est quand même le plus
fraudées il peut plus rien faire
maintenant maintenant est tranquille et
ses biens sont saisis
mais son incarcération ne ne change rien
au soleil avec d'autres il ya d'autres
personnes célèbres qui n'ont pas eu de
mandat de dépôt parce qu'ils ont fait de
la détention provisoire
aussi comme tapis par exemple
ou d'autres carignon la prison c'est
parce que je dis il a fait de la
détention provisoire et non sur jugement
ou nva et l'été d'été condé la prison
oui et en paca réunion les charges avec
un petit peu plus compliqué oui donc
leur carignan c'est plutôt de l'argent
public pour le coup et puis avait pas
que de l'argent public et qui la veille
avait trahi la corruption il ya eu ces
histoires de menace c'est pas le cas ni
la corruption c'est au mois d'octobre
après pendant la seule chose où je
pourrais rejoindre petit peu florence et
que je trouve ridicules pandémie balkany
en prison mais ce que je trouve aussi
ridicule c'est l'attitude de certaines
personnalités qui passent leur temps à
réclamer que toutes les peines soient
exécutées et qui sont horrifiés que tout
le monde aille pas en prison
systématiquement et quand là on met
quelqu'un en prison
ils sont choqués donc moi c'est pas ma
position mais voilà ce que je trouve que
quelquefois il ya des la peine de 4 ans
n'est pas aménageable tout de suite
alors que son épouse après trois ans il
a emmené sur la sueur des peine
aménageable chanson dans le coeur
il appelle enfin suspensif de la
condamne à six la cour d'appel il ya
valu à mandat de dépôt il va sortir tout
de suite ou pas le niveau
le même niveau de fraude c'est ce que
vous disiez il ya une question qui me
taraude
est ce que on est capable en mesure
d'aller vers une forme d'homogénéisation
finalement des jugements ce qu'on le
considère j'ai cru comprendre un peu
comme une forme de bouc émissaire pour
certains
d'une forme et il est monsieur malkani
peut-être considéré comme figure de
proue pour certains d'une forme
d'injustice
donc est-ce qu'on peut aller vers de
l'homogénéisation est ce que c'est à la
justice parce que vous une très bonne
question à ce que savait susciter des
tensions
c'est ce que j'entends j'essaie de
comprendre l'opinion publique pour
certains c'est une bonne question est ce
que c'est à la justice de faire des
exemples est ce que c'est à la justice
de faire de la morale c'est ça l'afrique
et le sait aussi
j'ai tout cela est ce qu est ce que
parce qu'ils n'ont pas un comportement
moral des lettons qui viennent faire
après après on pourra aussi 100 m sorte
de de jeu démocratique en dix ans
balkany tout le monde sait ce qui fait
depuis à peu près 30 ans à chaque fois
il est revenu au premier plan et a fait
valoir les gens sont ravis de justement
réellement donc voilà puisqu'il y aura
appel
elle a probablement va l'empêcher
d'ailleurs de se présenter
probablement ou là à la mairie de
levallois ce qui va si les traits lui ça
me posera dès hier une question
intéressante dit ça lui est déjà arrivé
mais il s'est déjà présenté il a monté
une liste alors qu'il avait été battu 95
milliards et aider mes rides et bien
c'est re se présentèrent maire élu au
premier tour
mais ce sera intéressant de voir quel
sur lesquels comportement des habitants
de répondre pour vous répondre
le pénal n'est pas là pour homogénéiser
puisqu'on est sur chaque cas individuel
à côté de lyon chaque cas est
individuelle donc on ne peut pas
homogénéiser pour tout le monde
les peines en dix ans donc c'est déjà un
du secteur donc il monsieur balkany
était jugé pour un cas individuels entre
ses deux maisons non déclarés entre ses
mains
voilà donc c'est un système c'est un
vrai système non mais encore une fois
c'est pas de l'argent public c'est de
l'argent qui vient vous aimons classe
qui viennent de loin mais oui sont des
deniers publics d'argent public personne
non personne ne conteste ça mais c'est
pas de l'argent public détourné
mais c'est pas une raison c'est pas une
raison c'est pas parce qu'on sait c'est
pas bien en ce cas là vous allez allez
jamais chanté en public donc ça fait de
fer privés
oui enfin c'est une affaire privée c'est
pas le même niveau même pas le niveau
tout ya 16 millions non non non pas du
tout ici entre les valorisations des
deux maisons non mais oui mais ça c'est
des chiffres qui peut et qui n'ont rien
à voir avec la réalité va mon point fort
je vais arrêter de toucher à votre ami
nationale alors avant mélenchon il ya le
parce qu'il va falloir parler du procès
de l'enfant qui était actuellement il ya
aussi on a appris que le françois fillon
serait jugée juste avant les municipales
son accord avec son accord son accord
lui même lui-même a donné son accord je
pense qu'il a donné son accord
quelque part c'est un peu aussi un coup
de pied sur ses petits camarades à l'air
oui parce que des coques de doubler la
mise et de la justice du barça c'est
l'agenda initial les annales judiciaires
n'a pas à tenir compte des agendas
politiques ce qui fait d'une balle jaune
avec fillon l'a quand même toujours été
bizarre la justice jamais réussir à
l'aide que pour s'attaquer à fillon
avant les présidentielles la l'agenda
veut que par comme par hasard ça arrive
avant les multi sites
non mais oui ils soient d'accord pour
emmerder tout le monde oui tout le monde
l'a enfin les a tous ratés enfin voila
je voyais président quinze jours après
il n'est plus rien donc on peut
comprendre que c'est un peu lâché un peu
énervé et contre sa famille politique et
contre tout le monde donc lui mais
pensez donc c'est intéressant tout ce
que vous dites parce que on voit bien
que il ya une intervention du monde
judiciaire dans le monde politique
bien sûr derrière derrière tous ces
faits non vous n'êtes pas d'accord il
n'y a pas une intervention là la justice
l'autorité judiciaire fait son travail
elle fait son travail
et heureusement heureusement au titre de
deux principes qui sont essentielles qui
sont fondamentaux qui construisent notre
notre ordre social notre politique
la justice fait son travail voilà alors
ce qui est nouveau c'est que tous les
tous les élus qui se qui avait maille à
partir avec la justice concluait par
j'ai confiance en la justice de mon pays
et puis là c'est fini même la maison qui
dit je n'ai confiance en personne
amen pas dans la justice bon mais au
regard de deux principes essentiels
enfin le le pacte social comme le deal
jugement de contre balkany enfin rendu à
l'égard de balkany est suffisamment
lambeaux suffisamment déchiré la justice
fait son travail elle est là pour ça
avec en effet une chronologie qui n'est
pas celle du monde politique ne vois là
moi je ne je ne vois pas d'intrusion
c'est à chaque fois que la justice fait
son travail on dit ah voilà juste
justice politique opération mains
propres mais paris dans le calendrier de
la sphère fillon on sait que les prix
dans l'accompagnement et c'était une
situation unique une situation
complètement inédite
l'afer est sorti dans le canard enchaîné
qui est généralement très bien informé
et je le lui
la justice le dira mais mais je feins
manifestement sont des sources très
sûres très fiable il n'y avait pas
d'autre solution que de que d'intervenir
pour la justice une rapide il est bien
sûr vient trois 2016 mais en 2019 si
tout ce qui était à charge jusqu'à mai
jusqu'à la fin des élections précédentes
étaient tombés pendant la can
jamais vu la justice ceci rapide pour
andré il ya un petit moment
entre ça il pose est quand même assez
bien sûr oui non mais le problème est ce
que ça donnerait pas de plus rapide
alors pour le coup enfin un moment plus
rapide ou plus long je ne sais pas mais
au moins qui est le délai qu'il soit qui
puisse être
il est indéniable que ça va que 1
préjudiciable à la droite qui ce procès
commence sa vie aux martys à l'ultime
argument c'est dans les recoins du très
jeune décision municipale de sion sera
pas rendue ce n'est pas moi c'est
préjudiciable à la droite parce que
après tout je vais vous pouvez de droite
et ne pas ne pas payer votre femme a
rien faire le berckois c'est pas payé
c'est ça oui
on n'oubliera pas tendu les rapports et
de gauche on n'oubliera pas de rappeler
d'où vient fillon où il en était de
resituer on peut faire c'est d'en face à
une certaine presse aussi pour bien nous
expliquer que c'est une famille
politique que c'est il était à la tête
de deux
de cette campagne électorale qu'il était
censé prévenir qu'il avait gagné la
primaire par rapport à tous les autres
on va tout relancer et vend la peau pour
plomber la droite mélenchon se dit de
son livre procès politique
le complot dans toute sa splendeur la
sortie de route qui continue le fin
c'est fini quoi les juges c'est
pitoyable
c'est du délire permanent n'a pas
vraiment le choix s'ils voulaient
défendre mais il ya eu une dénonciation
par une par une députée front national
et que c'est le seul à ce moment là
qu'ils étaient sur lequel est une paire
qu'il sait qu'il ya une perquisition
il y a eu des perquisitions au siège du
modem man et autres amis bayrou n'a pas
ordonné d'enfoncer une porte de bons n'a
pas malmener les autorités même
démissionné il est bon marine gernez cdu
si malheureux que ça en france une
dictature qui sera peut demander l'asile
politique au venezuela je pense qu'il
sera accueilli comme un héros ou super
sound efforts mélenchon donc à autre
chose parce que c'était un esprit
intéressant un esprit très durablement
je pense qu'avec des ces faits depuis
cet épisode film et en plus ça mais
c'est vrai que c'est vrai qu'on a vu
notamment les conséquences électorales
important puisse être là moi je suis un
élu de la république
c'était totalement ridicule comme si ils
étaient intouchables
est ce que parce que les a soumis ces
packs lui ça pose peut-être aussi le
problème de sa place dans ce mouvement
et peut-être que d'autres aussi envie
qu'ils ont envie de sauver la pauvre
après tout ils sont des dizaines de
députés
c'est un peu y ait eu un peu de
nourriture
bien sûr des députés notamment mais ça
ça pose aussi la question des des partis
en france un parti qui est tellement
identifié une figure à la la république
en marche
enfin dans une autre mesure mais c'est
pas loin d'être la même chose est
tellement incarné par une personne ça
fragilise énormément les choses
la france est soumise sans mélenchon la
république en marche sans macron c'est
plus vraiment grand chose et avec ferran
votre avis doit démissionner ou pas on
parle toujours des ministres qui doivent
démissionner quand ils sont mises en
examen
alors ministre je tiens mes chansons qui
a demandé à nouveau de ferran
l'attention à la présomption d'innocence
donc non mais ministre cet appareil oui
on a parlé est élu par les faire se dit
mais jurisprudence balladur qui a fait
pour le premier dit à ses ministres
il y avait une carignan car il va se
représenter à grenoble vous allez le
thème voilà enfin il a payé car ils
paient eux absolument il a payé
et d'ailleurs c'est pas inintéressant ce
qu'ils racontent sur la prison sur vous
faire une confidence
j'avais j'avais vu après sa sortie de
prison
j'avais moi si j'avais discuté avec lui
d'un fake comme quoi des hommes
politiques formidable et il m'a expliqué
sa vie en présent et il m'avait dit ben
arfa au bout de six mois il y aurait eu
des élections j'étais élu président de
la prison
avec sa lunette mais il se murmure que
que balkany aurait fait aménager un riad
en tout cas j'espère qu'il va avoir une
meilleure nourriture
à l'évidence il faut pas qu'il
démissionne en faveur on a vu par
exemple françois de rugy démissionné
pour cette histoire gros il se redit
démissionner alors qu'il y avait pas de
mise à mal être qui n'a aucun intérêt et
c'est de démissionner beaucoup trop vite
moi la seule question que je me pose
c'est comment est-ce que macro et
edouard philippe ont pu le laisser
démissionner au lieu de lui dire mon
temps les restes là joueurs on s'en fout
ça n'a aucun intérêt mais c'est être
clair en tête que celui des services aux
questions c'était location et d'extraits
fait curieux puis enfin selon ccc
ridicule c'est tout cependant il
suffirait de porter plainte contre
n'importe qui à n'importe quel moment et
hop on ferait démissionner les gens en
fin de vie les choses deviennent
ingouvernable ingérable et invivable
c'était mieux avant mais c'est pire
maintenant des catholiques et de la
politique c'est de cette décryptage
[Musique]
alors revirement cela dit des évêques
puisque le le porte parole de
l'épiscopat avec dix autres appelé les
catholiques à manifester contre la pma
et puis on a appris hier finalement cédé
plus compliqué que ça que au fond d'ici
les catholiques vallée manifesté peu
vrai que l'épiscopat lui-même ne va pas
appelé à cette manifestation
emmanuel macrobe avait appelé lui-même
les les catholiques arts à prendre parti
dans le débat politique
au fond ils le suivent je ne réponds pas
sur le fond est ce que je la parole des
évêques est sensé ou phare que jamais
mais quelques les évêques prennent une
position
ça me paraît presque obligatoire parce
que c'est ce que les gens recherchent
dans une religion c'est un peu un cadre
et une direction alors si à chaque fois
on dit ben non ça c'est un problème
successives à quoi serviraient les
religions si on est en des catholiques
c'est ça peut être intéressant que la
hiérarchie catholique diva ça c'est bien
ça c'est pas bien voilà après on est où
votent en sa conscience mais mais je
trouve ça absolument logique que nous
donne la religion n'avait passé pour le
main pour le marais ce pour tous il
avait passé pour mais c'est bien ils
n'avaient pas appelé de dit pas qu'ils
avaient manifesté en mai il n'avait pas
appelé à la manifestation les avait
laissés là il ya un moment ils
reviennent en arrière maintenant vous
faire un moment il ya eu un pas de plus
sur la paix m
il est tout à fait normal enfin mon sens
que les quelques que le brave comme les
évêques trace une route après on a su on
l'a su par ses c'est un autre problème
on la trouve
agréable ou désagréable l'autre
tourmentée mais c'est bien qu'ils aient
un cap sinon à quoi ce à quoi tout cela
servirait-il chacun chacun est dans son
rôle
en effet moi je sais qu'il faut se
méfier de cette cette identification de
l'électorat catholique est pas si
compact que cela le on a toujours du mal
à cerner ce que peut-être l'électorat
catholique parce que il est traversé par
des biais par d'autres considérations
notamment des considérations économiques
et sociales le cet électorat n'est pas
homogène
il ya les catholiques urbains qui ont
plutôt réussi dans la vie et c'est
qu'ils votent comme tous les autres
comme tous ceux qui ont qui sont urbains
et qui ont réussi dans la vie puis il ya
les cathos qui sont un peu en marge de
tout ce qui est mon allié de
mondialisation etc et qui votent comme
tous les autres
comme toutes les autres personnes qui
sont sur ce champ économique et social
si vous voulez donc il n'ya pas il ya
pas un vote catholique où il ya un vote
catholique et un vote catholique eux au
moment bas de françois fillon la droite
trocadéro lll et très imprégné par un
vote catholique massif le croit on
évalue à peu près 40 6% des cathos qui
votent pour fillon au premier tour la
présidentielle
bon aux européennes on considère que le
mil les cathos ont plutôt penché du côté
macro enfin du côté loiseau et auteur dé
belgique
absolument le côté ballet bellamy je
crois que c'est à peu près 20% pour ça
que ces catholiques comme un mot vote
et puis natale et l'oiseau ses 38 39 %
mais voilà et est de surcroît cette
qu'on pense pouvoir identifier comme
c'était l'électorat catholique n'est pas
y compris sur des positions dites
sociétal type mariage pour tous ou pma
n'est pas aussi aussi radicale aussi
mais oui de catholiques sont pas contre
marie fourtou non
contre la paix m de moins en moins il ya
une part de l'électorat catholique qui
est de plus en plus libérale de sueur
sur ces questions et on connaît la part
de poids
l'électorat catholique globalement alors
le alors c'est compliqué de catholiques
n'y a pas de statistiques mais cible
mais je suis assez sûr les questions
d'appartenance religieuse en france au
regard de l'universalité de notion de
citoyen mais on s'est toujours le
chiffre qui circule on évalue à peu près
6 % de la population
le volume de catholiques pratiquants
deux incidents occasion paul des
catholiques pratiquants -6% le on l'a vu
par exemple au moment où christine
boutin s'était présenté à l'élection
présidentielle et là c'est en effet
assez raisonnable de deux d'observer son
électorat parce que il est trés
essentiellement l'électorat catholique
parti chrétien-démocrate lycée et boutin
avait fait 340 milles fond c'est abou
voilà c'est vrai que le parent tout cas
dire démocrate en papier qui était très
important en italie notamment en france
c'est un mépris quoi la ctoi le mrp 1 à
wimbledon
là je parle d'eux mêmes au ballon ovale
récemment
sans excès moi ça me choquerait qu'on
résume le le vote et la présence car
tony key à christine boutin quand même
nationalité
donc c'était très homogène oui voilà ce
dia évidemment une certaine partie des
questions d'envergure il existe le tiens
voilà de 3000 personnes
finalement c'est bien d'autres choses
plutôt catholique le vote de gaulle dans
l'ouest notamment en bretagne notamment
municipal j'ai eu un vote catholique de
gauche qui a mené les socialistes des
journaux catholiques de gauche donc
beaucoup de gens et la plupart des
journaux tv ne résumons pas une
caricature on ne caricaturons pas trop
les catholiques très visible c'était
vraiment un bloc très très homogène
penser que la religion affluent comme ça
dans le comportement politique
ce qui me dérange un petit peu c'est
cette finalement sa petite immixtion un
peu catholiques
je crains malheureusement que ça empêche
un certain pluralisme religieux je
trouve que c'est pas à l'image du
paysage religieux français ça me dérange
un petit peu c'est avec vous alors si on
prend la vie si vraiment c'est l'avis
des catholiques
oui mais
c'est un peu je pense que c'est pas
forcément à l'image de ceux de notre
paysage religieux français voilà racines
chrétiennes de l'europe encore même nom
mais dans ce cas là pourquoi il n'ya que
les catholiques même pas ce qu'il s'est
passé le seul organisé aussi oui c'est
vrai oui c'est vrai on dit que le soir
un autre peut dire autre chose
attendre d'autres avis aussi légalement
quoi il a dit ensuite pays sont à peu
près et j'étais à peu près à peu près
d'accord je zoome sur le mariage pour
tous par exemple je proclame les
responsables religieux et des autres
pour savoir que j'ai été à peu près
d'accord avec peut-être pas les
protestants protestants sont
traditionnellement les plus libéraux
historiquement les plus libéraux sur ces
questions là si vous êtes bourgeois au
sens mal chronogramme bien gagner annuel
du terme à sa télé sans cette
intervention de deux barreurs bien
intéressante un battant mais qui
s'accélère c'est quand même un peu
caricature je sais pas ce qui met
derrière du terme d'un bourgeois basset
l'embourgeoisement non c'est
l'embourgeoisement de politique c'est à
dire oui mais c'est pas bien ce qu'il
veut dire c'est dire faites attention
être à l écoute de leur éviter un couple
de bourgeois qui sont en escale qui sont
à l'écouté de la rue bondée qui font des
actions notamment sur sur des aides sur
l'immigration bien sûr mais ça rejoint
un petit peu ce que je reprochais
jacques lang que j'aime beaucoup par
ailleurs s'avère que il a il a magnifié
il a déifié le moindre tiger crise à
l'opel de tous les murs de france parce
que je n'ai jamais eu un tag place des
vosges où il habitait donc ses tournées
on est exactement dans ce cas de figure
c'est à dire que le type du ballet taxer
très bien avec une sorte de mépris un
genre nouveau beaulieu un peu pourra
vous avez qu à mettre un petit peu de
couleurs ça va être gay ça va être
beaucoup mieux mais surtout ne venez pas
dans le quartier du marais puisque là
c'est joli donc par des bourgeois qui ne
croit
à l'immigration alors que les plus
pauvres sont le respecte et le
réceptacle
donc voilà c'est absolument c'est donc
lui qui nous laisse tout seul la parole
du président et d'or est derrière ça il
ya aussi éventuellement fin
politiquement un changement de discours
sur l'immigration parce que jusque
jusque là enfin c'est ce qu'on pouvait
penser au fond des gens libéraux c'est
qu'ils pensaient que c'était une
question économique qui se réglerait de
manière économique
or là ils ont fait une question
politique et on voit bien évidemment
l'opposition macron le pen qui se
dessine est d'aller sur le terrain
justement de deux du réseau bleu
nationalement il utilise des arguments
très sarkozyste la ligne la ligne
politique continue depuis depuis 74 76
qui s'exprime de manière à peu près de
manière différente il était question de
l'immigration de travail avec giscard
lionel stoléru l'époque qu'elle était en
souvenez le des ministres c'est un type
très très fort très fort vous reprenez
ce qui se faisait à l'époque le discours
utilise des termes différents
il a pris une résonance évidemment qui
n'a rien à voir avec à partir du début
des années 80 la montée du front
national sur cette question il ya en
effet une espèce de préemption de la
part du fn sur la question sur les
questions migratoires qui a fait monter
le
la tension dramatique monter la sauce à
titre clientéliste et et politiciens ça
montre en effet le la portée de la
réthorique d'extrême droite dans le
paysage politique français
mais dans le même temps si j'ose dire ça
éveille aussi les consciences sur le
fait que michel rocard l'avait dit enfin
les opales désir d'union mais la france
doit-elle prendre ça balance à paris on
sait jamais le deuxième on oublie l'as
wihr de la fin la jument il ya des
questions économiques
et puis il ya des questions je suis
totalement en accord avec mon collègue
et ami laurent bouvet il ya une question
culturelle
il ya des questions d'identité qui se
pose pour la pied pour fonder sa part il
ya des pauses prolongées qui se pose
comme un non seulement il ya des
questions qui se posent auxquelles il
faut apporter des réponses et en effet
les alors je sais c'est pas
nécessairement lié à des questions de
migration mais en tout cas là la
question de la je devrais même pas dire
de la cohabitation parce que dans la
tradition française s'est pas de
cohabitation qu'il s'agissait d'intégrer
l'intégration d'intégration au regard de
l'universel justement dont on parlait
tout à l'heure mais c'est pas faux de
dire que ce sont les les les individus
et les citoyens qui sont dans des
situations sociales très compliqué qui
subissent le plus les subissent le plus
directement ces questions de de
coexistence qui sont parfois compliquées
choisi sélective ou l'immigration
clandestine
puisque les migrations photo au fond je
trouve pour les réfugiés et les
demandeurs d'asile les immigrés
clandestins mais c'est vrai que sous le
thème immunisation certain montant
global dans lequel il faudrait en effet
je me pose que là quand il parle
d'immigration oui et parle de
l'immigration en matière de manière
générale non la réponse n'est pas là
même si on parle d'immigration choisie
d'immigration sélectif je me pose la
question de quoi parle-t-on dans les
zones rurales c'est vrai qu'on fait
souvent appel par exemple un des
médecins qui viennent de l'étranger des
dentistes qui viennent de l'étranger est
ce qu'on parle d'un échec pour ces
personnes où on parle de la semaine
dimension sociale dans le problème
l'immigration il ya eu bel s'est parlé
et en effet les enfants d'ambassadeur
des vaccins il voulait dans les start up
here ya quelques il ya des immigrés
notamment qui ont commencé des start up
très peu un jeu très peu
voilà mais vous avez raison de poser la
question parce que c'est instamment au
global mais on est aussi dans un débat
qui est assez un débat de postures aux
réalités ou le discours prime sur les
actes parce que au fond il n'est jamais
vraiment positif figuration bal gascon
dit qu'on appelle l'immigration choisie
avec les quotas etc
ça existe et existera existe depuis
longtemps le la france n'accorde à
cordes des titres de séjour au regard
notamment des qualifications
professionnelles si elles existent de
ceux qui d'aider des personnes qui
demandent à immigrer en france qui
viennent de l'étranger au regard
notamment des tableaux qui existe qui
est consultable j'ai pas s'il est sur le
site du ministère l'intérieur mais enfin
il est d'un accès très simple au regard
d'un tableau qui dresse l'inventaire de
ce qu'on appelle les métiers en tension
c'est à dire les métiers dans lesquels
on manque de main d'oeuvre
je pense par exemple à ce qu'on appelle
les rippeurs j'ai appris que ça
s'appelait des rippeurs c'est à dire les
personnes qui se tiennent sur les
camions de collecte des ordures
ménagères et qui voit là oui mais ça
s'appelle non parce que le reaper et
émouvoir les rippeurs l'eia le chauffeur
jean charles qui vient de l'anglais qui
je sais les américains bah oui mais
c'est le coeur
l'officiel 57 lecture on appelle ça des
rippeurs des prud'hommes mais c'est en
réalité ça existe en effet choisi c'est
un sexy mais c'était peut-être
intéressant va y avoir un débat donc à
l'assemblée nationale sans vote
mais et c'est vrai qu'il vient un moment
où finalement les chiffres de
l'immigration sont relativement faibles
il n'y a pas de yap a fondamentalement
pas vous regarder toujours des surprises
me gratton le clemi grattoir n'ya pas
mais y ait une situation vous avez
raison de l'âge et clair qui est parfois
mal mal supporté un peu dommage c'est
qu'on parle pas des succès des
migrations tu marques tu n'as pas idée
de ce qui peut être négatif alors qu'il
ya des vrais succès notamment aussi par
des gens qui partent en province où ça
se passe très bien
voilà je trouve ça dommage qu'on ne
donnent qu'une image un peu grise mais
il ya un succès sur fait mais bien sûr
futur ghanam à face à ces débats ce
qu'on voit le plus on parle toujours des
trains qui arrivent en retard
non non non mais quand on parle de
problème de l'immigration s'ils vont en
effet pas d'une pas la question du
succès qu'on aborde le vimeu sous
devrait quand même avoir un paysage un
peu globale de la situation
oui et puis arrêtons peut-être un peu
l'hypocrisie on est peut-être dans une
logique prospective électorale et donc
on se dit peut-être que
les ministres allemand et ça va être
intéressant d'ailleurs parce que tel on
va tous les thèmes de la prochaine
présidentielle et alors que c'est pas
dans notre première préoccupation
d'après les sondages nous faut se méfier
des sondages parce que quand les gens
disent c'est l'écologie qui nous
préoccupe souvent été aussi pour faire
bien pour responsable mais c'est bien
mais si c'est aussi un discours selon
lequel on va toujours à fleuré beaucoup
trop mou jeter parce qu'on a peu en
verve et si je dis ça on va me traiter
de ce sinistre mais cela c'est aussi sur
le déclaratif des gens on leur dit est
ce que les migrations la même sur les
sondages et n'impose n'est pas la bonne
on voit bien quand il ya des problèmes
posés par une non assimilation d'une
partie de population donc cela on peut
toujours dire qu'il ya des succès bien
sûr une intégration assimilation des
mets déjà pas intégrés y en a ça ça ne
manque pas et c'est ça qui pose problème
colts de barrie effectivement partout
des gens dans les villages mais mais
mais quand même de deux femmes voilées
dans un village de fin fond de la
normandie c'est comme si on avait vingt
mille à paris peu importe le nombre
c'est que c'est l'impression qui compte
et c'est comment les gens ressentent une
revendication ressenti des blessés mais
c'est exact c'est vrai mais c'est toute
sécurité on ressent les choses après
est-ce que c'est raide je sais pas mais
les gens le ressentent
on passe et l'éclairage et on va pas
l'être start up et d'avocats alors venez
vous conduira par les avez-vous des
start up puisque le président de la
république a reçu ce qu'on appelle la
french tech et que cinq milliards
d'euros d'investissements
institutionnels vont être donnés s'il
peut dire aux start up
c'est important d'aider les start up
c'est effectivement important est d une
start up c'est c'est important pour
l'innovation l'innovation qui est
facteur de croissance et d'emplois
directs voir indirects moi ce qui me
pose un petit peu problème s'ils
voulaient c'est qu'on parle
effectivement de montants exorbitants
c'est très très bien mais qu'on parle
également jeu sid de licorne
oui il faudrait peut-être qu est ce qu
une icône parce qu'on ne peut pas les
citer c'est licorne en question on peut
les citer monsieur n'aime pas facebook
google voilà ce qui fait vraiment rêver
et on parle c'est les gars forts les
gaffes a cédé gaza j'ai pas ce qu'on va
éviter cela ben justement j'espère que
ce ne sont pas celles qui on donne des
impôts
la liste est tombée on sait exactement
où aller les 5 milliards donc non mais
l'objectif si vous vouliez c'est d'ici
2020 je crois que c'était le
2024 ou 2025 d'avoir des licornes en
famille c'est le mot licorne en fait qui
m'interpelle un peu plus si comme c'est
quoi ce délire s'est désisté et réussir
il ne les a plus d'un milliard voilà
exactement et et à quelles qu'elles
soient retoque on va sélectionner est-ce
qu'on va sélectionner les start up qui
son hernie stand où on va plutôt
sélectionner des start-up nature c'est
vraiment moi la question qui est très
important c'est a priori tout ça a été
fait puisque n'ont été sélectionné que
les start up qui avait levé un minimum
de 150 millions d'euros
enfin je viens on sait tout ça il ya pas
de surprise non mais il est décédé des
services et de ses de stone peut-être de
lutter ou de donner une conférence au
vog afin dire pour l'instant c'est comme
l'amérique les états vie qui dominent le
monde de la nouvelle technologie
non si vous voulez ces startups ont déjà
prouvé start up dont vous parlez ont
déjà prouvées la viabilité de leur
business model c'est très bien on est
plutôt dans des start up qui sont dans
une stratégie de déploiement
d'industrialisation
on est d'accord et donc se sont pas
forcément ses entreprises ses start up
qui ont des difficultés pour faire des
effets de levier les start up qui ont
beaucoup plus de difficultés sont des
start up qui sont en lice touch c'est à
dire très en amont
et ce sont ces startups qui ont besoin
des dons et vous par exemple comment ça
se passe comme quand vous avez créé
votre
start pubis alors en l'occurrence quand
vous être incuber et ça ça a été mon cas
j'ai eu la chance d'avoir des avances
remboursables j'ai peut-être pas pouvoir
citer et dires qui décrit j'ai eu ces
avances remboursables mais si vous
voulez la situation financière d'un
entraîneur d'un start over est très
complexe
si on veut le matérialiser on a une
courbe qui traite complexe et à un
moment donné à la base de cette courbe
on va se demander l'entrepreneur va se
demander doit continuer ou arrêter parce
qu'il il va il va y avoir des
difficultés pour lui pour trouver
justement ces effets de levier
donc il est des entreprises ont des
autres d'entreprise quel type
d'entreprise puisque l'entreprise tout
en effet très suivie les investissements
il ya des sommets qu'il faudrait qu'ils
aient décliné par là une maison
d'édition qui se passe exactement les
mêmes soucis où il ya un moment ce débat
est ce que ça marche ça marche pas
qu'est ce qu'on fait il est malade on a
du mal comment créer vos luttes a fait
pas dead
voilà l on vous accuse je ne vais pas
dead est ce que la partie de la start-up
les chaînes hélas le dock financièrement
en tout cas mais encore une fois on peut
pas toujours tout critiquer ce que c'est
très bien que de que comme le disait
patrice carmouze
c'est tout ce domaine là est préemptée
par les états unis
là on a des filles ont sectionné qui ont
de fait un travail remarquable qu'ils
ont levé de l'argent qu'ils ont du mal à
franchir le pas suivant ok ça sera très
bien de s'intéresser aux start-up
débutantes aux bébés c'est très bien
mais c'est autre chose
là c'est pour lutter contre les états
unis pour développer tous cas
intelligence artificielle est fort
techniquement et on est on est faible
économiquement
ce qui ne veut pas s'occuper un jour des
entreprises qui se créent avec 1/2
ordinateur et de personnes c'est très
important
mais là on est sur un autre niveau donc
c'est très bien n'a donné de l'argent et
on se lance et on va on va essayer de 2
de faire jeu égal avec les états unis et
bravo à moi la question qui me que je me
pose c'est licorne oui très bien alors
mais le risque c'est quoi c'est que
finalement c'est licorne aussi pour
beaucoup
s'érige un peu en bastion inexpugnable
avec un frisk de frein un de frein à la
violence et de bain on en a beaucoup
parlé on en a beaucoup parlé mais
parfois comme vous le disait très
justement ces boîtes là avec cet afflux
d'argent vont être créatrice de de
richesses et d'emplois il ya des gens
qui vont rentrer lancer dans ces
startups qui au bout de quatre ans
auront pris tout ce qu'il y avait à
prendre le 7 de ces startups et qui rend
fonder une plus petite etc
et c'est à ce sera un cercle vertueux
sinon on ne fait plus rien moi je suis
plus pour ce que j'appelle une forme de
démocratisation économique une
décentralisation et économique en aidant
le plus grand nombre tout simplement
voilà mais ces deux oui c'est d'une
stratégie politique
le rac milliards sur l'agrégat des
startups en aidant à beaucoup de
startups en misant que sur quelques de
swat a vu voilà mais ces deux là c'est
plus une stratégie me semble-t-il d'état
et qui pour être assis européenne
d'ailleurs enfin plus que tout ce que
nationale mais il est en effet de faire
une concurrence
on parle des avocats juste une question
il ya combien de start up qui ont été
retenus qui vont entrer des socialistes
de sambre 151 les avocats la grève des
avocats
alors c'est quoi ça les privilégient qui
vont dans la rue alors privilégié des
gens va peut-être heureux si tu fais des
choses c'est pas parce qu'il ya des
avocats très médiatique qui gagnent
beaucoup d'argent que tous les avocats
sont à la même enseigne
ya problème de retraite info oui c'est
un fan dans l'annoncé sur privilégié de
la manifestation la manifestation
portait sur la retraite puisque la
retraite est de faire une retraite
unique pour tout le monde et de
combattre en fait est de supprimer les
régimes spéciaux
alors nous sur notre retraite des
avocats
nous sommes caisse autonome donc on
n'est pas un régime spécial puisque on
suit la loi sur l'aja d'un âge de départ
à la retraite sur un certain nombre de
points mais on a une caisse autonome de
financement de nos retraites qui est la
cnbm la caisse nationale des barreaux
français
cette caisse a une trésorerie de 2
milliards 7 est très florissante mais
c'est entre nos cotisations puisqu'il
n'ya que les cotisations des avocats
donc vous voulez pas payer pour les
autres
c'est pas qu'on veut pas payer pour les
autres c'est que à la limite si on payer
pour les autres
mais là dans la réforme pour le moment
nos retraites
on paye après une cotisation de 14% il
en faut juste préciser par rapport pour
les professions libérales en général on
n'a pas d'employeur donc nous on paye
contrairement aux salariés on paye part
salariale et par employeur en même temps
on paye tout donc actuellement on est à
14 % de cotisations sur nos revenus et
là on va t'on va passer à 28 % de
cotisations sur le revenu donc on va
doubler les cotisations nous c'est
énorme et c'est énorme pour les petits
cabinets donc je pense qu'il va y avoir
des petits cabinets qui vont fermer
boutique
moi je vois ma collaboratrice qui me dit
bah écoutez moi si finalement tracé
travailler pour ne payer que mes
cotisations
je vais aller voir ailleurs et je vais
arrêter des travaux car tu peux plus
aller
qu'est ce magazine en finance les
artisans financer un certain nombre
d'autres caisses de professionnels des
problèmes sont en déficit mais c'est un
des problèmes de dos de la volonté de
regrouper au fond dauphin 2 a donc
glissé que n'est pas un régime spécial
on est une caisse autonome on
s'autofinance
et surtout on a un régime qui est un
régime avec une partie de solidarité
c'est à dire que on a une retraite de
base qui donne des pensions la même
tension pour tous les avocats quel que
soit le revenu qui est de l'ordre de
1500 euros ce qui est quand même pas
trop mal par rapport à certains membres
de retraite et ensuite supplémentaires
c'est en fonction des revenus qui nous
donne des points
donc honnêtement je vois pas très bien
pourquoi on supprimerait cette caisse
qui ne coûte rien à personne puisque
nous on n'est pas financé du tout parlé
par les fonds publics comme la ratp la
sncf etc donc je comprends pas très bien
pourquoi on va nous supprimer cette
quête celle et vous étiez très nombreux
oui dans leurs nouveaux besoins des gens
soient absolument et tout mon coeur est
avec une partie donc on était six
avocats sur huit être en grève
donc sur les 2 jaunes étant plongé à
porte voilà la misère à la misère
aucun temps passe alors non pas parce
que c'est de la question des retraites
pour passer au duel si vous voulez alors
on est tombé sur un article du monde qui
de 10 voilà que la voiture plaisir c'est
fini ou ne vend plus de décapotables de
petit cabriolet
c'est ce que c'est triste ou pas jean
charles vous pensez que c'est triste
qu'on abandonne là alors on va faire du
lc autres vous pensez que c'est triste
et stéphane mon sens il s'en fout un peu
me contant le mot est faible je m'en
fous la voiture plaisir bien évidemment
parce que d'abord je vais quasiment une
invention française zéro tout le monde
aime bien mais on est bien dans sa
voiture la voiture c'est quand même
l'indépendance c'est le plaisir est dans
une belle voiture et c'est surtout la
liberté alors la liberté pour vous
d'avoir une dalle est aussi maintenant
la liberté d'avoir une poubelle et de
rouler dans 21 dans lequel voudrait même
pas monté et puis ma liberté d'avoir une
voiture que je trouve jolie kate
agréable et caetera et je n'ai jamais vu
quelqu'un le dire non je veux pas monter
dans ma voiture j'ai préféré prendre le
train
ça peut exister mais il faut en avoir
une encore bon et faut avoir cette
volonté mais au delà de l'anecdote la
voiture plaisir c'est surtout la voiture
liberté c'est de la liberté de se
déplacer quand on veut comme on veut je
sais bien que ça va être compliqué
dimanche à paris meilleur titre et
d'écologie punitif qui va bientôt
devenir une écologie dictatorial où on a
jadot qui nous dit qu'il va falloir
décider que les gens voyageront en
transport en commun et pas autrement
donc là on est dans une écologie où il
ya plus de plaisir du tout bon - vu mon
âge j'espère que je serai mort avant que
ces gens-là et pris le pouvoir
mais voilà donc je revendique le fait
d'être au volant de la voiture d'être
avec qui je veux dans ma voiture et pas
comme dans le métro avec des gens que je
n'ai pas choisi et voilà donc je suis
content je roule aisée plaisir à y aller
là je vais quitter l'émission de
télévision
je vais aller où je veux comme je veux
je n'ai pas à me soucier de rester fort
parce qu'il en va pas voir l'otan oui
pardon pardon d'exister jean-charles ma
poubelle m'attend et vous permettrait
que j'aime que je m'exprime aussi bas
c'est vrai la voiture c'est génial la
voiture en plus décapotable etc qui
permet de respirer le bon air pur de nos
deux noms de nos zones urbaines de nos
villes de ses vrais que il m'arrive de
prendre mon véhicule terrestre à moteur
pour me rendre à mon ballon rond à mon
travail à la faculté de droit et j'ai la
chance d'habiter à 5 km de mon lieu de
travail et il m'arrive de mettre trente
minutes c'est vrai que c'est un plaisir
génial de rouler moins vite d'arrivée
moins vite que si j'y allais à pied les
étapes a appelé parce que j'y vais à
pied lorsque je le peux mais c'est vrai
que je prends un plaisir non dissimulé
dans une poubelle à être à l'arrêt et
puis surtout la voiture ça ne coûte rien
c'est ça qui est génial ça ne vous coûte
rien c'est un plaisir tout plaisir et
ses coûts pour moi la voiture plaisir
c'est la voiture autonome c'est la
voiture dans laquelle je vais monter et
qui me conduira sans que madge
conduisent pendant cette trêve c'est
d'avoir un chauffeur
c'est pas loin d'être vrai donc ma vie
les transports publics les chalets vous
dire j'ai un chauffeur un chauffeur de
métro chauffeur de bus
un chauffeur de rer qui leur globalement
ce sont des systèmes qui fonctionnent
pas si mal ça il faut aller voir souvent
ailleurs comment ça se passe quand je me
regarde je me désole mais quand je me
compare je me console pas vraiment
placée et magdalena vous aimez la
voiture bah moi je préfère la moto donc
temps que la moto mais j'ai j'avoue que
j'ai hâte de voir la voix le véhicule
autonome à malo et il faut quand même
dire que il ya plus de pollution la plus
de pollution dans le métro que de
l'extérieur dans la ville dans la ville
exactement dans son rôle en toute
connaissance de cause il faut qu'on se
dépêche puisque à dubaï on teste le
drone
le drone déjà le taxi qui vous serez des
réponses de votre boulot et bancaires
paquet amazonie avec un sens oui madame
apple a déposé malouines livraison de
bouquins avant il ya plein de nourriture
parce qu'il n'y pas déjà des autorités
merci merci beaucoup à tous les câbles
démissionner est terminé merci beaucoup
magda nous manquons de glisse stéphane
minson
jean charles lajoie ni et florence
mercadé à très vite pour un nouveau
numéro de paf
[Musique]